here's huo plays it back towards cry pass was
tipped and now on the Counterattack kachuk for
the r away kachuk right in BL WRA maybe got to
call on that great luck for Boris kachuk after
the turnover just inside the Chicago Blue Line
played well defensively they have not been able
to score this is a bad play by huo here going
back in a poor giveaway to chov for the races
how about this Pat sa just as Mark with that
68 up there on this fourth line with d and Sint
and a shot turned away by marrom as the Hawks
apply a little pressure this 20 months dealing
with mental health and got a welld deserved
loud Ovation when he was introduced to start
the game the city and the organization have
been remarkable supporting it there's a big
hit by Coleman at the line knock rle off the
puck Here Comes Shillington mapani back leg
shoots glove save by moric who hangs on and
now Zer out to hubero with cadri going to the
goal cadri sto miric down able to cover up hubo
looking for a rebound and Peter morazzi hangs
on Hawks off the draw Puck around the boards
calling Blackwell feeds it in here's Anderson
Stu by Mar what P save there sustained pressure by
this line for the plains bapani it's to work with
a play to tan tan to mapani backlin Sharp ble cut
off by morazzi Tor check Phillips doesn't have a
stick bapani gets the puck to tan here's Hanahan
again Hanan nice move Hanan put wide moric may
have got the piece but chip back in front moric
down Puck still loose what a play by hannahan here
as he'll just go right by and no finish misses the
top half of the net that's the second opportunity
blackka checked at Center by Reel and away he
goes reel triy to split the middle reel right in
STO by marks rebound to Ste onle Puck bouncing
great chance there for the Hawks Magna shoots
Boxster makes the save and whistle puts it down
low Anderson able to break it up another chance
for rles he's had a lot lately just can't score
why well another good save by marstrom here as he
comes across beautifully he's been hot early
now shikin trying to clear can't get it past
Sanford kachuk shooting a marks got a piece of
that put it off the glass the puck goes out of
play another chance for kachuk tripped up as he
tried to work it out of the corner picked off by
Felino behind the that in front Rish sto by Mar a
Point Blank Range another good look there back to
the line to Phillips lock the handle Haniford
tried to get it in front picked up on the near
side by cornado the quick shot up high on morazzi
who makes the save and hangs on Pinsky settles it
down and brings the puck to Center B ahead for
reel there's a onetime Sanford stopped by marrom
Sanford on the power play with a good look one
of eight stops by marstrom so far in this one
catri takes the pass banked ahead swi can't catch
up to it f ahead of Joey Anderson down the wing
with a long shot a little bit of an awkward save
by Mark number one here the way the Flames have
played in that first period particular middle
the can see that coming Alex blasic able to
steal at last moment prevent a shot fli out
Tado dive chops it ahead final minute of play
in the Peri here's reel Ed can't get a clean shot
away caught up by Anderson angles him over to the
boards classic sticks with it here's Dickinson
nice pass Blackwell GL St markstrom marstrom
with the glove able to stop Blackwell who scored
twice in the first meeting of the Season Flames
go coun yeah he's got three goals two against
the Calgary Flames so he likes this team that's
a great save because bar coming from one side
to the other Blackwell smart enough to come
back against the flow in one time it doesn't
get all of it cry Cuts behind the that turns
to the foram put it in front Sherry can't
get a stick on it Isaac Phillips good play
to chop it away here's a break another chance K
right in stopped by marrom another breakway and
marrom with to make save there to keep this one
goal is KF this time he picks it up beautifully
and there is the save again as marks him
stays right with him and stares him down
afterwards and there's the move he'll bring it up
stolen by cadri in on Magna cadry makes him arm
double shoot stop moric with a good sa cry back
to Zer moric with a stop on the one Tim by Conor
Zer C in a good look cuz he took a spill
still got it up high big stuff there by
moric off the shoulder pass to Leno play
inde moric out round the board L picked it
off with a shot Maric able to scramble back
yeah it was very similar for that goal the
other night and uh marzac we haven't talked
a lot about him but he's quieted his game
down positionally pass tipped lams recover
cadri Len back to cadri now Hanford over
to cadri cadri sign the go k the front it's
SC Len tucks it in power play B makes it one
nothing and he gets one here finally a good
setup here by the calvary Flames they move
it around and LOL with the first good pass and
then it comes right back to it and gets a bit
of a break and maybe that's what he needed in
the team needed as it goes right off a skate
of stenor and then right back onto the Stick of
lindol and just like that after berserk now maani
shorthanded works the puck inep plays it in front
Sher oh it's got a shot away stop by morazzi and
that'll bats the rebound into the corner first
of all a short-handed chance here maon he uses
some good speed on the turn back almost finds
Sharon goich in front back he does AZ with a
good save as this Puck Ricochet right to a boy
that was a real good save byzic there and how
about this Rush here by Philips coast to coast and
marstrom again we're going to count steered Away
by Isaac Phillips he'll take control and hand up
ice Phillips leaves the rush try to split the knee
sto by marstrom great Rush by Phillips markstrom
shuts down the five hole and he's able to hang
on over to H blash it behind the net stolen by
Coronado put it in front to L with the shot stop
Ric stopped the rebound too Sharon goldage with
the second chance came to the Forefront here and
there's lolm with a good chance and now the pucks
Bank to the line and up and onto it is backland
Coleman racing Down The Far Side takes the pass
stopped by morazzi way out the challenge and he
makes the save and hangs on and and then the two
on one at the other and how about moric that's a
good read I mean he tan gets the pass to Coleman
now bapon able to find him in her own as he works
it in trying to break through the knee Bon stopped
by Mari oh that was going to be pretty Buck comes
loose but they blow it down G some speed through
the neutral zone and soon as you miss that poke
check as a defenseman you get yourself in trouble
and then marzik Saves the Day on that particular
play haxer on it dick with a chance to get it
up firers the pass over to R EG with a shot
BL save Maron and he'll hang on as he makes
his 29th save of the hockey game good play by
the Hawks to beat the icing and that sets up
this chance and R is RI might have been over
the net but nevertheless markstrom Falls it
down may not have been over the net I don't
think so at Le see from that angle Han hands
wanted him to go for it here's a chance on
the back hand Rish sto by Marr and he lays
the glove down and covers up passing up to
Pino out the way with a shot marks him with
the sa Jones in deep played in front cut off
by the flages P trying to eat the Pu can't
do it C lets it BL pass it rebound stop by
marrom dickon great look marstrom better save
and the Flames hold on for a one- nothing win